I know you're uh tight with Deshawn
Jackson you guys are from the same Hood
uh what's it like having like a guy like
djck you know it's SP on the de homies
that's he's a legend Hall of Famer
future Hall of Famer yeah for sure
future Hall of Famer going crazy on game
that's bro de homies I I know he was
doing the what was the name of his label
you could probably help me was it
jackpot I was going to say jackpot yeah
I know he was doing that he got the
jackpot [__] rolling do you ever try to
sign you nah nah he probably regrets not
trying to sign you no but he had a like
you know a legit reason on the dead
homies on c g that made a lot of sense
so on G what was his reason well you
know you know some little inside [__] it
it was a legit reason that's fair yeah
yeah that's fair legit reason for sure
for sure uh you just signed a big deal
congratulations yeah um I saw I saw uh
it's geffin right yeah shout out to good
talk shout my guy Johnny shes okay um
what was the the bidding war like for
you though cuz it had to be like yeah it
wasn't like they're the only people
trying to sign you n yeah it was all
type of people tapping it how many
people were trying to sign you Empire
[__] they all tapping in who from
Empire was trying to talk to you Gentry
[__] I don't remember no [__] name
just tell me I [__] got to go through
my text is hey I'm with you from with
you hey I'm with you yeah so everybody
everybody was trying to get at you yeah
for sure so what made you especially
like after like I posted cuz everybody
thought I was signing wack cuz I took
that picture of wack and A Wack
conversation like kept popping up but
after I posted like I'm not sign nobody
was do that [__] like on my St yeah I
think I I I I heard like I thought that
you might have been signed with whack as
well yeah everybody thought that so
after like I posted like on my story
like I'm not s I'm getting my story like
be rolling getting G of view so what
made you choose though Gein and uh good
talk those guys cuz they were just like
you know everything they touch turn to
Gold CU I mean they just like you know
they was talking right have you heard of
that Mexican OT obviously that's your
label mate yeah he just got a gold
plaque yeah you're going crazy me and uh
I went to Houston with that Mexican OT
and we went hog hunting h we was
murdering hogs out of out of a
helicopter I want to hunt out a
helicopter out of a [__] helicopter
me and OT was [__] we had the [__]
AR-15s that's sick and we smoked we
probably killed like 10 pigs great yeah
there's a vlog coming soon it was a good
time man you should you know what I
think that people like hunting I never
was like a hunter ever this is the first
time I ever hunted but I was like oh
this is kind of like you know if you
want to get some aggression out just go
a helicopter though that's like kind of
like you know you'll think you'll start
with simple just you know on the ground
so we did that you like you Tropi up cuz
that's what you call Trophy and up cuz
you really trophied up straight to the
helicopter and then at night we uh we
did like a 2 a.m. hunt where we had like
night vision goggles on and we like
stalked a bunch of pigs and then we
found them and just put them down that
[__] did y'all like go go go go take
them in and eat bacon n we just left
them there oh cuz they're pest they're
like uh they're like pest to the area
they're they're Youk do you eat pork I
love the pork okay do you hell yeah
[__] the swine is Divine I'm black
[__] I eat pork [__] first of all a
lot of black people will say they don't
eat the swine no pork on my Fork I hear
that all the time I got my best friend
in the world is black and he will not
touch yeah that's true but they they
they really like deep down they really
like want to do this [__] I why you
would need Pig it's so good and a lot of
people that be saying they don't eat
pork on the day homie they get byself
and really do it up listen you know
turkey bacon ain't good that [__] bunk
run that [__] is
trash get you some real [__] bacon
come on girl a real deal some pork chops
come on some ham with the red rooster on
it imagine that's the only hot sauce I
eat too reder I can't eat no other
really hot sauce like really so likeed
typ straight Red Rooster and Tapo Tapo
solid I do I like Tabasco on my eggs I
don't eat nothing else cuz like what's
that sauce that come with the Green Top
cuz Green Top you talking about Tabasco
no no uh on a dead homie just got uh
with the Green Top cuz it's like red
it's like clear come in the clear
container that's tobasco sauce no it's
not Tobasco it has a green lid it's like
it's tall though it's like a tall can
it's like tall it's clear the sauce is
like
red I'm going to show you on a DI no not
Tabasco not this srra on [__] Sriracha
Sriracha you like Sriracha no I don't
eat that yeah Sriracha is gas lie
honestly like I can [__] with any hot
sauce I feel like as long if I open the
fridge if I'm at someone's house and
they make food and I'm like what you got
is whatever they got I'm like I got to
[__] with it yeah cuz I can't do that
bro I'm picky as [__] on a deal I are
you picky with everything you eat hell
yeah like will you eat oysters yeah so
you okay well you're not that picky
that's jail that's jail food though bro
they sell oysters on the jail list well
I mean listen I always if someone says
they eat oysters they can't be that
picky cuz the real picky [__]
oysters that you put that in a spread on
a day I'm us do it up wor just good so
what is like something most people eat
that you won't [__] with uh that most
people it's a lot of [__] that most
people I don't eat tacos what the [__]
well it's really like the it's the corn
shell I don't eat the shell but you do
flour I don't yeah I do a flower you
don't like corn tortillas no I don't eat
pickles onions ketchup mustard
mayonnaise so no my burger just like got
meat and cheese on it that's it yeah I'm
like a simple eater cuz you're like my
kid [__] 10 I I eat simple cuz we go
to the drive through and it's like
cheeseburger plain yeah plain
cheeseburger so no ketchup no onions no
pickles no mayonnaise no mustard none of
that [__] just like might throw some
bacon on near how do you eat a hot dog
just
straight uh put some uh put some pork
beans on it D put some pork and beans on
it with some cheese on [__] and crunch
some hot chips on it okay and do it do
it up like that but no sauce noce you're
not a sauce guy unless it's red rooster
yeah unless it's red rooster but that
don't go on a hot dog no no no no
doesn't I mean it could go you never
know you do that [__] on the D me you
nasty hey you're going to have a rough
day at the uh the restroom for sure yeah
damn no tacos and you are from La yeah
[__] the taco trucks are amazing we at
the best taco trucks in the country here
yeah I yeah but you eat a flour taco
yeah I eat a flour one though or you eat
a burrito yeah I eat a burrito CU with
just like meat and cheese and that [__]
and rice you like Pastor the stuff they
shave off with the with the pineapple on
the top no I don't get that just do aada
yeah you aada or like sometimes chicken
or I might feeling fancy cuz I might mix
you might do both might do both give me
both give me the steak you you [__] with
like seafood though
right um if it's like fried like fried
shrimp and like but you w have like a
cold shrimp cocktail n hell no damn it's
got to be like a certain way it's got to
be deep fried yeah okay I respect that
they have oysters in jail hell yeah
oysters macro wait how the [__] do the
oysters come in jail are they in a
can not in a [__] can they come like
in a [__] uh they can come in a they
some prisons like they serve them
different some come in a pouch and some
come in a low can [__] too some D coming
I would not want jail oysters no it's
like the regular oysters from the street
like you go in the grocery store that
same brand in prison bro I like oysters
on a half shell on ice and then you
slurp it oh like you like the real
oyster yeah I'm talking about like
oysters bro at the grocery store bro I
never had those trench [__] [__] bro
like I see that grocery store oysters
grocery store oysters with the noodles
you [__] with
sardines sardines that's like the fish
in the can sardines oh yeah oh yeah yeah
not like that though cuz but I had them
in the spread before a couple times on
the de homies